- hello Super Trouper nation we are here
once again your friends your comrades
your leaders your best friends I daresay
your only friends and a lot in this
world that really care about who you are
everyone else hate you yet this is your
one place you can come to get away from
all of it because so say it from anyone
you know cut off everybody you love in
your life and come here watch this
Buckeyes every Tuesday and Friday
those we are not a cult but we are truly
is not a cult but we are truly the only
ones that actually know and care about
you on a real level they already cause
that hi this is daddy foo bhishm Xmas is
that this is the weirdest fetish like
our Kelly
he had his girls call him daddy I don't
get the whole daddy thing why would you
want that why would that be well you're
go to like I don't know there's a lot
wrong with that guy so yeah he's going
to prison oh thank you to rake on rake
on here but thank you to them to sponsor
this episode of the podcast
this is freeform baby we're out here me
and ela we out here doing it our way
like Burger King but it tastes good
we're off the rails this is no yeah our
Kelly's going to prison they got him and
I think they they took his bail away as
well I don't know if he's going to
prison yet you know well some on somehow
it's still undecided like what is there
to decide well he needs a try it's
clearly up to no good by my boy Dan
correct me if I'm wrong but they they
removed the possibility of him posting
bail because he's a flight risk so he's
in prison
correct he's in jail and the technique
is in jail awaiting he's real waiting
trial exactly and usually you'd be able
to post a bail yeah but because he's a
flight same with with everything which
that they're like dude that's the one I
was thinking it's kind of funny it's the
one time being a billionaire is there's
a drawback
kind of always a plane yeah I mean like
of all the scenarios in the world you're
like damn this is the one time I don't
want to be a billionaire because the
judge is like there's no bail I can give
you where you're not gonna just bounce
to Saudi Arabia but at the same time and
being a billionaire is the only reason
he's not in jail up until now that's a
very good point you know so maybe
billionaire in the long run was a good
thing for him and then no jociel opinion
got your purse controversy yeah I mean
from what I'm reading lately
apparently so many people knew about it
for so long Epstein man that guy crazy
crazy business I don't know if we could
talk about it this early in the show I
feel like and it is actually true the
YouTube Raiders they give you more like
you talk about the more controversial
stuff towards the end you can get away
with more are you sure you want to say
this because I forgive another shooting
yourself already said that's their
policy okay it's not like a loophole
it's their actual policy like they have
a policy of like if you curse within the
first 30 seconds you're gonna get
screwed but you can they give you more
leeway towards the end because they know
no one's watching or maybe that's just
our show but at the scene yeah we should
we should talk about that after the
break because I can't even say the guys
name without Raiders being like huh they
got their finger of the mature button
let's talk about some good news before
we get into that TMZ saves YouTube let
me say that again
TMZ sent me an email that completely
blew me away I mean this is
unprecedented proactive so commendable
policy I'm gonna read this email I am
just I'm floored by this TMZ save
YouTube hello so by the way just to
preface this story we showed a lot of
teams Eclipse in our previous episode
with the baby boss and they claimed our
videos and I disputed them which is like
we don't even make money on this podcast
anymore because every episode has like
10 to 20 different claims by the time
you dispute the mall it's like the money
gets lost you know YouTube says that
you're supposed to get money from this
escrow account
I have not some evidence of that ever
happening I have a feeling like that a
skort doesn't even exist you know where
that escrow account is YouTube chase
account YouTube um yeah yeah rainy day
funds yeah what do you call it that
little piggy bank yeah yeah they're like
yeah it's an escrow account what they
mean is we keep the money and you
[ __ ] idiots keep fighting actually
I've been talking to my rep I'm like ha
I'm like okay when do I get paid is
there any proof that's what I'm trying
to get at I saw him on his ass I'm like
okay so I won this dispute a month ago
there's no earnings it says it's at zero
so where's the money at
because we should have seen a spike like
there's no spike there's no earning
because okay let me get back to you then
he comes back to me says okay so you're
you get it three months later and you
should see in a spike good luck good
luck following up on that but so I'm
good I'm gonna keep writing his ass and
I'm gonna say is there any evidence I
need evidence on the server sit but how
like this is a high level guy in YouTube
and nobody can show me evidence
it's not in my an oh then he goes it's
won't showing your analytics so imagine
there is so where are we listen we need
receipts here yeah and HD podcast so I'm
on I'm on them hot because I want to I
want to know that the system's actually
working because so far this guy who's
super high up in YouTube a friend of
mine has not yet been able to confirm
that any of that money from that
supposed escrow account has come to me
like it's a nice story they know and
everyone's like okay cool escrow account
but I as far as I'm aware no but
ever been paid out so all these well
these big companies are getting paid
mm-hmm other thing a lot of people just
don't dispute it yes so many of our
friends whenever we ask I'm like what
did you do about it nothing I don't want
to deal with it what yeah I don't know I
think it's just it's very intimidating
it is and you have a special ability to
handle this stuff I feel like it been
through a lawsuit the only one in the
history of all [ __ ] platform even
still you get into the details of it and
you're like wait what is the law and
they're like I'm gonna understand the
law which someone else wouldn't do first
of all you thank you for the compliment
you woke up in second of all you're
right I would have never gotten in that
lawsuit to begin with if I didn't care
about the details mm-hmm because from
the beginning I was like [ __ ] you yeah
this videos fair use [ __ ]
and so and and well now when I write my
so it the legal language of the YouTube
DMCA is written to discourage people
from abusing it so they write a very
scary little do they know I'm starting
to understand as I learn more and more
about these claimed farms is that
they're all so scared they're only able
to get away with what we allow them to
because it's just a bunch of people
sitting in a room trying to claim and
gobble up as much money and they rely on
people's hesitancy and unclick and I
think says if anyone is being shady it's
them what are you doing you're actually
making content ELA of course I'm fully
convinced that if there was some
large-scale class-action lawsuit in some
way organized it's hard to find a law
honestly I just think they're exploiting
a huge legal loophole but they know that
the thing is you have to prove bad faith
and I think the simple fact of their
existing a claim farm proves I think is
provable and if you subpoena those
emails with the managers and all the
people making Commission on claims
you're gonna find bad faith out that ass
maybe but it wouldn't be so like we'll
have to be like a federal investment
like a criminal investigation like FBI
[ __ ] more than I actually look at
everyone's emails but who knows you know
yeah if if I was uh Atlantic Records the
FBI would be so far up their ass they be
[ __ ] in Mexico right now trying to
hide from the feds but the point is that
they're just as scared of someone
rebutting them as you are of them
because the legal language a document
and now when I get a complaint a claim
does what I say
and I think I'm the only one on YouTube
who can say this [ __ ] well that you can
cite it mm-hmm I say I have previously
fought fair use in court or not in court
and I have previously fought
I lost a lawsuit and won and I go in
parentheses who Saints Auto V Klein I am
prepared to defend my right of fair use
you need to remove this claim
immediately supination guess what
happens they always drop the [ __ ]
case but I think that all the other
youtubers out there could cite the legal
precedent too I mean who say you could
say fair use has been previously
defended on YouTube and Husayn fine and
fair use what won a resounding victory
that this case is precedent that you
have no claim to this video and you must
drop it immediately so because when you
just send that to some dumb intern who's
just as scared as you you know as their
instructions are hey just [ __ ] you
know they're just like easy money
they're just gobbling up easy money when
they get something like that like hey
mother from someone mentioning lawsuits
and legal precedents to like [ __ ] this
also for them it's like a quantity game
right right so if one responds with a
scary thing they'll just drop it because
never really 100% yes so that's the
preface of this is that TMZ claimed all
her videos like it happens all the time
but they sent me this email a couple
days ago they says hello my name is
Maddie and I run YouTube operations for
TMZ I just wanted to reach
out and let you know that I've seen some
consistent disputed claims from your
channel and after review I've decided to
whitelist your h3 podcast channel and a
new podcast highlights channel let me
know if you have any questions or
concerns you also she also Maddie
providing me their direct line she said
he or she I'm not sure if it's it's Matt
it could be a girl yeah really like
right could be a girl right then
yeah let's go with yeah
yes Maddie okay you have my direct line
if anything comes up in the future and
provided me their direct communication I
mean that I was blown away I was like
dude that is so mature that is so nice
this is what we need more of and this
equals so nice to actually have
communication to write from TMZ of all
people to you know team Z surprised me
consistently somehow these guys seem to
do the right thing yeah
besides for being like also on the other
hand vultures
but they'd small paparazzi thing yeah
the whole paparazzi thing that you know
besides harassing Justin besides for the
very essence of their existence no but
this was a really great email that I I
was like wow as a classy thing to do I
never even considered such a thing so
now is the perfect time to start for us
to start reloading their content in its
entirety all right like what call a tea
pot got slash TMZ sorry uploading all
the paparazzi videos no I'm kidding take
note other companies out there this is a
this is a huge huge play a huge an uber
match play mm-hmm excuse me
uber match sounds very Nazi doesn't
isn't it wait what no a mensch
what does it not man yeah uber match
yeah a super mensch
yes they say that well why not see cuz
it's German
uber is very German word really I don't
know it was German it was very Nazi word
I feel like it means above it means
better than and the the the German term
for like the master race sounds just
like that they say I don't think it's
meant well so that's what they call this
in the uber race
greater race the soup yeah so Wilbur is
superior to taxi to what it's a regular
taxi is that one like uber the app oh
yes exactly
uber oh no it it is ubermensch yeah uber
Mitch know that that oh no no no but met
but see Mensch must be yeah it means
something different in german uber man
looking at the wikipedia article right
now it comes from Nietzsche the
philosopher oh hell yeah we're going
we're going deep here but yes Nazism
that is the term connecting übermensch
ubermensch concepts or theories is not
well maybe they are over man
and a bench is a concept in the
philosophy of free of of Nietzsche not
now I'm now let's click [ __ ] it I'm in
it let's see it means Superman beyond
man over man hyper okay is a concept by
Nietzsche a a goal of humanity is set
for itself it is a work of philosophical
allegory with a structural similarity to
some other [ __ ] I've never heard of
but it's like what we should what we
should strive to be super humans in the
the origin of it it had a more you know
not Blair yes not with low eyes and all
that co-opted by the know there's like
it was like ubermensch yeah we should be
super attractive that's what he meant
arm well that's a preference we should
all have blue eyes and blonde hair
that's what he meant
by the way I feel like that is I just
learned a lot I only I didn't never
heard of that we educate here on the h3
podcast because I always I heard like
the Aryan race I heard those stones
goober much there you know and on the
other hand I knew of meet you but I
don't know you connecting dots here
where's
trans ma world all of a sudden yeah but
I felt that the concept of the Nazi
ubermensch is a weird one because
honestly I know like maybe maybe Hitler
liked to [ __ ] blonds but
fair skinned is deaf far from ubermensch
like those [ __ ] just drop dead
when they Sun hits their skin like black
people don't get like skin cancer nearly
as much as like you take some of these
redheads from like Ireland you just had
fetish probably blonde blue yes
uberman CH like crunch the numbers do
that's not even genealogy or whatever
you eugenics right it's how they call it
yeah if technically if you wanted to do
like survivability darker skins better
right Dan yeah that's that's right that
Africans are the real master race that's
what we're learning here today well
they're also the original race that
that's true and apparently Jesus was
blocked too if you go back far enough
we're striving off path so in short
thank you I've got this anecdote about
Zach our sound lad that's the sound lad
we went shopping his dad is a is a real
estate agent and he showed us a couple
houses and they narked on Zach so hard
he's not here today but I guess we'll
have to follow up with him on Friday
you're gonna be listening and I didn't
ask for [ __ ] his mom came to for some
reason so both of his parents were
they're nice people really great people
total ubermensch is uberman Chester
they're Jewish so that's an internment
that's an under man I speak a little
German
they're men and so first they say he's
that got a haircut because he has this
long luxurious hair yeah wait what yeah
he got a haircut then they go he broke
up with his girlfriend which apparently
is been dating this girl for a long time
and I'm like I wonder if that has
anything to do with Belle Delphine
sniffer underwear oh no and then I find
out that Zac narked cuz I was saying
that we were looking for a new house and
Zac narked on me to his dad who's an
agent and then his dad he didn't want to
give my information to his dad because
he respects my privacy and his dad ends
up getting out of him because he gave
him a two hundred dollar Commission for
the lead by the way I never said [ __ ]
this all came out of them and then
finally the Coupe de Gras was that they
said he was sucking on a pacifier till
he's five years old and the only way
they could get him to stop is by doing a
pacifier ceremony where they destroyed
it in a flame like they all held hands
and say goodbye to his pacifier what
that that one's not real nice sweats
[ __ ] God in life they've met they
volunteered all this information I
didn't say [ __ ] they literally just
showed up to embarrass him but so we
have a lot to talk about on Friday their
characters his dad is a funny man he's
like mr. realtor you know he's got a
convertible Mercedes you know his mom
was rocking the Gucci shoes is he big
enough does he have a job ads we see him
around town do you see what do you see
you know how like Realtors they always
have those cheesy photos that they put
on like yeah he's about that that's
low-level [ __ ] he's mister let me make
some calls
you know he's got the pocket listings
you know what I'm saying right yeah it
really does he's guys like yeah he made
our current realtor look like a [ __ ]
little I want to say it actually you
know what what am i doing what are you
doing they all listen to this you know
this is what's problem here like I and
this is so ridiculous right now I just
realized that our realtor listens to
this show and he always comments to me
about it no it's just what it is I mean
this is the world that we live in
well if I can't like how am I supposed
to do the show if I'm not picking Oh was
my realtor gonna think about what I say
like how could I live my life like this
because ultimately I'm here for you
people and I'm the only one that is here
for you
yeah remember that well Karl if you are
listening to this don't worry we're
still with you baby
and sax dad if you are listening we're
still [ __ ]
we're actually not even looking for a
house this is just saying there's no
house I live in a hole I feel like I
have a feeling and so I was feeling that
Karl only listens surface-level for
chitchat so if he brings this
conversation up then I'll know he's a
real fan thing as I know Zacks dad's
gonna hear this because obviously Zack
works on the show and he's gonna show it
to him but the real test so Karl if you
bring this up to me a conversation now
then then you're my guy because your
truth yeah and there's there's really no
way there's nowhere in a bubble that
someone's gonna listen be like hey Carl
did you hear this all right it's just
Carl yeah yeah meanwhile Zacks dad's
like nobody please [ __ ] tell Carl
Zach's dad wants that Commission so bad
I can feel the desperation out of it out
of the phone when I talk to him
I gotta make sure Zack it's like more
than 200 bucks if he ends up selling me
a house that's true
cuz the Commission on that [ __ ] isn't
huge as that got ripped off yeah $200
the lead this is a hot lead Zack you
sold my ass out for 200 bucks I'm worth
more than that bro you'll be fair you
did say that he had to really squeeze
yeah well that [ __ ] and these that
need a lady's a lead the dad his dad
goes his dad was I had to pay it sack
200 bucks and then a mom is like he's
just kidding because she's like maybe
don't isn't it fine you're in a family
the mom is so sane and then the dad is
such a character like what what is going
on with what is going on what is that
anomaly and why there's a mom always
like
families where it's the opposite I've
never I have hmm
a friend of high school whose mom was
just total off the wall and our dad was
just so stoic okay well hold on your dad
was your family what your dad was stoic
and you're what is pretty whacky what
what is stoic it's just serious no but
like my dad was such a character
he's like insane well okay those are two
different because your dad's not okay
you know what the point is again we're
being we're going way off back there so
tizzy but in short thank you to TMZ that
should be a thing whenever we go off
track in short thank you to TMZ it but
but was funny as Zach's dad was like I
pay him 200 bucks and then the mom was
like I could tell she was like don't
this is funny
I say he's kidding he's kidding yeah and
I look at them both in like he's not
kidding
I know he did but he's good he's really
trying to help and we do appreciate it
so it's not so but if Karl you are
listening then I got to cut him out of
the picture well see I don't think Karl
will say anything cuz this is what are
we in like 30 minutes Dan uh 23 so he
might mmm I mean maybe we should put
somewhere we should put his name in the
title
Karl don't leave Sachs dad is like
setting him on a goose chase like hey
he's like at his house like I'm plugging
this Internet okay okay the great
anecdotes a full of anecdotes here on
the HD podcast Ethan Bradberry is back
in the news Bradbury be good to your
mother
hila made the most hilarious observation
last night we were going over this stuff
she goes Ethan Bradberry at this point
is just making content for us because we
need to watch and you guys need to
what we're talking about but I was
telling you thing like do you understand
what's happening here and we're watching
a video that he basically made for us it
was like because I feel like what is our
life it's so funny that Cracknell
because it's so true because I don't
think this content has any inherent
entertainment value to anyone else
except us and viewers of the show like
the regula had by the way the regulars
doing well so I feel like almost a
hundred thousand views and it started at
five thousand it was which was also
general buddy yeah that's true but that
was such a funny point you uh and I feel
like Ethan Bradberry is putting on this
Godfather persona is so heavy that he's
blurring the lines between meme and real
so much that nobody knows what's going
on and I giving around his friends and
his family don't know what's going on
with Ethan like he came on this show and
he's like what's the mean what's the
mean and now he's so far down the meme
hope he doesn't know who he is anymore
yeah but let's start here he's in the
upside down words so he's keeps going
down this meme hole of like the god the
Brad the the Bradbury father the
Godfather is a better way to say that
the berry father I like that so it's all
about could be good to your mother
Andy Joe Gambino region to the front of
me and heart of Brooklyn New York City
you be good to your mother coming great
that's good keep it that way she hasn't
given me a call in about two months
and drink it wrong Rossum let's not call
them no it's not
I see the cream and sugar come over yeah
I'm becoming almost such passionate
kisses and bigger to your mother being
rate to your mother keep it that way
capiche got beat listen I might take you
down to the church and then the pair
right after cuz you've been good too but
it may be even said to tamp like to get
the jazzing about that he forget about
it who you get or what the area I think
his friend is just so flustered by this
and they're standing so close together
for audio listeners they're standing
like an inch from each others face and
you can just screaming in his face his
friend just is trying to keep up he's
flustered and I love how he calls him he
goes House of the coffee is at raw and
the raw as we've decoded it means black
coffee and he goes is it raw and he goes
it's the raw so they're all trying to me
him trying to get he's like no it's not
it's not
I see the cream and the sugar who are
you kidding and that ain't raw so he set
him up and then he knocked his ass down
could you can you imagine Ethan
Bradberry ask you is it raw and you say
no I'm fear for my life
the man's a psycho I dare tell Ethan
Bradberry it's not wrong so the new
logic is that if Ethan didn't gonna call
didn't get a call from your mom then
you've been good to you Amaya see at
first I thought it was bad that the mom
did write in on it yeah but as we've
decoded exactly you are not getting a
call from the mom is good because he's
been good to his mother so if you have
been giving your mother troubles she
would be call him and she call Ethan to
say yeah be good to your mother I got a
call what do you do two months ago Ethan
Bradberry I need you to straighten out
my son ain't be good to me
you've been good to your mother I've
been great to my mother what does that
mean how great can you be to your mother
what are you doing for your mother
you've been great to your mother what
does he send bride where is mom think
about him
you better bet if Ethan Bradberry is not
great to his mom who answers for that mo
mo is the ultimate let's read the
caption here
always a pleasure catching up with Andy
Ricci at 5:30 a.m.
if you ever never catch him you can find
him in the root of New York City
strolling the streets just to remind him
of a straight streak streak streak why
might streak I felt like it said steak
but sorry at aneurysm his Street
continuing to be good to his goddamn
mother oh he's on a streak okay remind
him on his streak can do I'm confused
with this written because it doesn't
this doesn't make sense
remind him on his streak continuing to
be good to his goddamn mother it's just
one less mother ringing my phone ranting
about their kids to me and it and it
brings me tons of joy be good and stay
out of trouble kids capiche
[ __ ] yeah the only comment that shows is
how the f is this N word verified
because you don't understand because
you're not good to your mother so anyway
that's the new stick and it just goes
deeper and deeper and so that's it so
pre lewd to the regular to which just
recently came out called the regular
Megillah and you need to know about the
mother paradigm to really understand the
regular schmegle
does anyone follow I think they follow
is let's we got to take a break Dan we
have to take a break right yeah so let's
do it
well we'll come back to it so it's a
short break we only have one sponsor so
I'm gonna run to the bathroom so if I'm
not back immediately if you see a empty
chair
give me like ten seconds okay all right
see you guys in a minute
it's 2019 ela everyone needs a great
pair of wireless earbuds and before you
go dropping hundreds of dollars on a
pair you need to check out these
wireless earbuds by Ray Khan ray Khan is
doing it right let me show you this
slick little design do you see that
that's cute is that a tiny little box
with a charging port so you got the buds
inside the port and if you're on the go
all you do is plug it in you keep it all
together and charges inside how slick as
that is pretty awesome it's magnetized
so it's super satisfying to open and
close I love it inside you've basically
got the CIA's top secret technology it's
so slick and it's so advanced pops right
into the ear like a beautiful dream what
really blows my mind is actually the
quality of the audio you get out of this
little device I mean this this is truly
from the CIA from the government this is
top secret technology and here's what
something else that you don't see us
other people including I've got a weird
ear hole I got an XL ear hole you uh do
you do I think I do I think I'm Excel so
you know they've got X they got extra
small to extra large so that you this is
gonna figure ear like a dream the
quality is amazing they f it is amazing
the price is even better folks compared
to what's outside out there the
competition give me a break dude guys it
comes with free shipping on all USA
orders you got free returns and a
one-year warranty so really give it a
shot you got nothing to lose they are
stylish discreet there's no dangling no
stems it's a bluetooth headphone with
all the great sound and the great looks
look at all these color options here
you've got pink a black brown blue white
and also my favorite color forget about
it because you need these ray cons go to
buy rake on Comm slash h3 to get 15% off
your order
that's buy rake on Comm / h3 for 15% off
rake on wireless earbuds if you been I
in a pair now's the time to get an
amazing deal so one
time guys bye recon calm /h three
beautiful
[Music]
hey mom nation then I would see this is
what we need sponsors we need more
sponsors you know we're back so Brad so
down the Bradbury hole we are wait we're
so much further down the Bradbury hole
than I ever anticipated that being said
let's pop up where I died a site like
this is like a wormhole that's a really
good analogy
we're in UFO territory you know how
black holes apparently tear the fabric
of space-time cuz they're so heavy it's
like nobody knows what's at the center
of a black hole the singularity it's the
regulations now when he'll for the first
time so here's the regular to the
regular Megillah so right now that's
4,000 views and that's even after the
success of the first one which was a
smash hit I like that but there's a cult
following for this now let's throw it to
the comments real fast been waiting for
this Papa blessed be good to your mother
capisce that's me Wow be good to your
mother capisce I don't want any more
mothers right give my line issue podcast
has entered the chat yeah well here we
are let's watch love the house this
therapy cop ready to eat some [ __ ]
pissed
I feel like you would know better than
that oh come on Ethan what are we doing
it wait wait I don't remember that why
is he on the John taking photos what's
he taking photos of sitting naked on the
toilet I think he's just checking his
phone
you know like watching some thought it
looked like he was taking a photo like
look he's deaf oh maybe not maybe he's
watching some heels yeah there's a
reveal in a moment so watching his own
bro what that's the intro who's taking a
[ __ ] watching the first one and then
yeah I think he's watching this one oh
he's mine yeah it's like nested in
itself film this is the owl production
slavery keep up are you kidding so
here's the gang hey I love what watch
first of all there's a couple things to
keep faster first of all Tennessee then
is just barely hanging in there what is
he on I think he's just on like he's on
the rock he's on you know what he's in
withdrawal from pranks yeah he's just
he's barely hanging on he doesn't even
know what's he doesn't know why he's
there he doesn't understand but he's
like I'm gonna keep an open mind what
won't go along with you guys look these
guys have been through a lot together
he's right or die so I respect that but
when he thin Bradbury calls then the
crew for a regula yeah he's like well
you know and and and Dennis see he's
view of centric this is the the brain
master of spider-man exactly
so when Ethan Bradberry pitches us the
Dennis II who sees himself as really the
the brains he's he's more than he's the
so G was the director that made jaws
Steven Spielberg he Spielberg of the
gang he's the director and Ethan
Bradberry pitches the regula he says Tim
we go into Starbucks and I asked for the
regula and then I started screaming and
I pour a cup of coffee and to Dennis II
he's thinking nobody's gonna watch this
nobody's gonna watch it doesn't make
sense Ethan's lost his mind
yeah he still read your diet that's the
face that you'll see on Tennessee right
now and then the other face that you
want do want to follow is mo somehow
just only is fixated on this dude like
he really wants to [ __ ] this dude
there's no other interpretation
nuttin yeah now let's start over
good Carla should I not spas it's six
minutes I'm gonna come apart now you're
gonna possibly give it a little bit okay
either you tell me what I'm good okay
I'm a poly before them
get - [ __ ] yeah big news
man just got Tommy Wiseau vibes yeah the
music good look at mo okay sorry I gotta
go back already
look at mo in the home we face they're
practically about the two of them I'm
not listen even but mo so the other dude
is awkward and he looks away because
they're having like this stare off but
mo never back down from the stare off as
you'll see okay I'm sorry
no don't go back no we watched it to New
York City I've been heading down to the
church and bouncing up there were a few
friend of Mines I'm thinking I've
included a few Finn of Mines
i'ma get to these guys in a second and I
won't be where the bottom introduced
them to you I've been getting a lot of
confusion to what this wrong this
regular rich was anyways I got a dentist
cut up front of me on our now open
I got Andy Ritchie to the Rebbe hey
listen welcome to your brother Boone all
yeah we were tap dancing and let me tell
you son you're like cool about 40 mm you
love the ring he gets super violent with
the ring sometimes I'm afraid he's gonna
break it but the regular ritual he
throws to the spoon that's my favorite
you know I'm not trying to pause this
last time I got a mother call on my
phone ringing my life was about two
months ago she tells me she sees Johnny
and Muno tap-dancing on a beefcake under
the Verrazano Bridge and I said to
myself Daisy I hang up the phone right
then and there I got Johnny Johnny
you've been good to your mother
we got g-men the man with the game I got
Kenny Caruso stop gonna be nicer what
[ __ ] nice or what'd they did a switch
a rule word Mo's the crazy one now why
did he say it twice I feel like they
totally switched there's so weird like
if you throw back to the beach pranks
when Ethan is like scaring mo yeah
anything is like circling circling mo
and staring him down and being like What
did he say what did he say to him now
let me pull that up for reference
because you guys have to know about the
role reversal dude has I guarantee you
you will not find this level of in-depth
analysis of the bradbury brothers
anywhere else like what the hell we're
like us we are we are historians of the
Bradbury's Beach pranks Bradbury
brothers now the end of this video um
why can I not remember it's killing me
we always like my friends you bet we did
about with him so he but he's like
visibly angry that's the part
here watch this we had so much right on
behind the scenes make sure you go the
back so he wasn't a crazy unpredictable
one but now I feel like moto that roll
things that you've been talking to me
nice a walk been [ __ ] nice a walk
there's been a lot of confusion I don't
know what's going on most [ __ ] lost
it but with the brother like Ethan it
was only a matter of time you've been
talking nice so what you've been talking
Nautica record scratch you have the same
mother they're brothers so I think they
finally moved out of that grandma house
I don't think so on the table yeah no
this plastic [ __ ] what's the
point living a house where plastic
covers every goddamn thing the table is
covered in plastic like the trees are
covered in plastic this appears to be
covered wow what is this a crime scene
or a goddamn living room Dexter like we
goofed on them for that like five years
ago and well I guess it's not their
couch what if it is their couch I think
it is cuz look at that poster oh you
just put it over in the painting at that
hour are you guys still living at home
yeah
you guys gotta move out and they're
bringing all these people over that's I
was just about to anything that he's
good to his mother that ain't good you
Martin get to the mother good point
you know Wow evidence to the contrary
but I'm I'm amazed that he was able to
pull together so many dudes for this
nonsense you know at 5:30 a.m. to
apparently but anyway they got the wrong
so let's continue as to what this war is
what this regular ritual is is the raw
is the most strongest purest form of
coffee formula out there
I want dismission because I feel like it
helps with your thinking what are you
out of your lab rabbit rabid-ass mind
that's right Oh rabbit s fine it's it's
intelligible if there was a subtitle it
would say intelligible unintelligible
the opposite of intelligible saying you
can't understand it right is intelligent
is intelligible come on eat then Maddie
mine maybe should be a subtitle
intelligible we need a fart mic like
Tama Christina I just farted but you
guys can hear it anyway oh it smells so
bad though sometimes your farts just get
that next notch of smell or you're like
oh your mother can smell it we got going
on over here I'm missing another cup who
got my other color and I seen you robbed
my cup I think it's a slave cops these
[ __ ] are driving around and
like out it like $150,000 please but
they still live at their parents shoot
at their parents else nice so we have
the coffee already prepared they don't
have what we're looking for in that raw
shop we're gonna slam with the regular
ritual you ready
as long as you're good Oh what did that
frame say you put it right and he hit it
yeah it's not in my document though why
isn't it in my document he's been it's
not really that profound he hit it he
hit us with a with a hidden frame here
it was that like 1 250 or something
right we're gonna slip well what the
regular bit yeah [ __ ] was right after
that already so he had it his off if you
just know how to seek with them it's not
worried and oh that's nice
oh you're secure bro you're a legend ok
he says dear future of Bradbury this is
a
secret frame allowed me not to get
attached to anything that isn't written
for me and grant me patience and times
of hardship and raw we trust I think so
that's a hidden message Jerry there's
just one frame right one frame what does
it mean actually maybe more than one
frame it's actually get that wrong one
two three frames yeah so cuz you
definitely notice it you know you notice
it anyway as long as you go to your
mother got beige yeah but you got to
understand the raw to the Roy's up there
what do you think advanced style I love
this it really has to becoming the
silent legend actually including Dennis
yeah just because he goes along with
them that's what I'm saying bro you know
you guys hit him with that three minute
and a half intro that's the hallmark of
the regula you hey I gotta hit him with
that Bradbury into it Oh at 75% in
that's what makes the regular the
schmegle I love it
so this is my another thing with the
like epic b-roll and then just suit like
cut to our iPhone like epic Stacia
Johnny come over you - oh yeah I've done
a call from your mother's hmm not good
in Sam be good to your mother's capiche
lady but they say having gonna call from
your mother in about a month
oh that contradicts what he's saying
good said okay great
come on babe kiss his lots of kisses
that's that got beat up a lot - kissing
lots of tender kisses
get it going Joe come on babe he said he
got a call but they say he didn't get a
phone I wonder who called it them
Bradbury taking the lead like Reservoir
Dogs to the nearest Starbucks
[Music]
buckle up
I like how he calls it the Ross shop
yep horse how you doing it so let me get
the regular regular
regular schmegle angles they got angles
regular Megillah
let me get a lot like live regular
smegal so well hold on I'm confused now
because the raw is just black coffee
yeah
and he's at Starbucks asking for the
regula which as far as I know is just a
black coffee yeah I guarantee you that
is what you want
she's like a regular large coffee that's
the raw but then she calls it coffee and
he's like no okay it's a terminology
issue cuz she almost served him yeah
then she clarified but I wonder if it I
wonder if the video what it just ended
amicably she handed him a black coffee
you know but I'm like I'm like Ethan
that's what you want that's raw a
regular coffee yes that's the regular
you know you brought your own cup you
ready to go they do have it that's
what's so frustrating to me
Ethan they have it you ordered it you go
I think the fear sets in dynasty board
shorts and polo what's the point of rain
the coffee machine it's not plugged into
anything
so that's epic we are uncomfortable the
manager where is the generator not good
mother
the manager picked at the lowest point
nine one one watch it
get it bad bear
you know he can really get a good scream
yeah I was just yelling a public kind of
his thing he's gotta talk that managers
on the phone with the police
guess you're just laughing at them to
everyone's kind of just they've got
black coffee then we get it going so
again there's no this is covered one of
them was super wet so again there's no
intrinsic entertainment value to anyone
who doesn't I mean the original one
doesn't have any intrinsic value until I
mean until we found it yeah it's like Oh
or that you need to refine it's like
have you seen a gold nugget a raw gold
nugget it's does it's not a beautiful or
a diamond even as a better example a raw
diamond just looks like a chunk of stone
but you need someone to find the diamond
to polish it and to chisel it until it's
beautiful to bring out its luster a
diamond in the rough it's true is what
the expression you know means and I
really do think the regular should be
called the rough because it's a diamond
in the rough and at this point but I
have a lot of confusion now Ethan
because you've been very consistent with
the terminology they have the raw 1 & 2
if you're gonna tell me that your
coffees more raw that you brought from
Long Island that's been stale for like 2
hours then a Starbucks that's what I'm
saying where's the generator I mean you
got right ela bring I bring a
gas-powered generator I don't like the
coffee machines is something yeah the
regular hot so here's what I page here's
what we need for part 3 yeah bring a
generator into the Starbucks you got to
pull the string and get the
gasps the the gasoline motor generating
heat and then you warm the pot irregular
and then forget about it you know that's
like you see I like to see him set up
outside of Starbucks and try to sell it
yes power generator there's a lot of you
got any other ideas I'm sure the list
like some people will buy it [ __ ] God
help but yeah I think you're right
someone might recognize him you have any
other ideas I like that idea what did
you have to bring more cups than five
yeah that's true that's true
hmm Ethan what else I think if you
shaved your head and eyebrows it would
be funny Dragonball Z style that's Joe
he is kind of gone Super Saiyan what can
we do I mean that's that's a good party
Danny see it needs an upgrade of some
kind
I think he's proven himself enough I
think Tennessee needs to be walking
around like a giant Cup costume remember
a Aqua Teen Hunger Force the cup like he
should go dressed as a giant cup that
was Master Shake thank you then I don't
think you would he's above that yeah
he's a director he's Spielberg Danny C
Berg that doesn't work Dennis Berg um
Dennis Bay let's move it on that's a lot
that's a lot of regular we have a lot of
fun on our HD podcast do we not we learn
we listen we grow we thrive here
together if you're listening I just want
to say here we are boys listen I listen
there's anyone I don't know that
anyone's listening they turn it off by
now yeah I'm saying most people are not
listening
at this point it's incredible that
people listen though it is I still don't
really think about it that like
actual people listen listen to this
right well I don't have any actual proof
like you see the numbers but well no
that's not Trevor I've run into people
who were listening as they said hi so
that's my proof that's my only proof did
you look at the phone though I didn't
actually hear it yeah
nor did I look at the phone to confirm
it was what they were listening to so we
should talk about something else oh it
was me alone you know so man spreading
chairs man spreading chairs now let's
move on to something even more important
get a load of this lady
look at her smarmy dumb face you're so
stupid you're just annoying so I'm gonna
show her I'm gonna set up her whole
argument what do I have a problem did I
say something wrong either well look how
smug she is about these stupid [ __ ]
chairs so I read the article okay Wow
mrs. read the article what are you in a
woman's chair right now I'm gonna be on
her side for a moment okay she doesn't
take herself that seriously she said she
does see the humor in it and it was
meant to start a conversation about
women taking more space in life that's
interesting that she it's a metaphor
yeah because the article the crimes who
knew very serious about how she won
awards yes she did win an award but the
work is not to start selling these
chairs at Starbucks now it's it's an art
piece it's a design piece but with more
like to start a conversation hey are you
done yeah I just made some wine deal
look at her
look how smarmy she is her arms across
just like her my legs should be at all
time no I'm kidding that's a fair point
it's good that we we don't paint with
too broad of a brush here right you look
yeah no I see boats knives on this one
what because I I kind of said he's fine
yeah
that's all inside but but people are
taking this seriously exactly
let's put and also it's more fun it's
more interesting if we take it from that
route
it can't be so reasonable that this
shows boring you know I'm saying get out
of here with them stop with this reason
and logic in fairness you know it's not
entertaining you've been good to your
mother
I've been great to my mother okay we
should call our moms
you should check in on my mama Ethan be
good together
he's been great to me the end of
manspreading
student fed up with men and fridging on
her public space wins National Design
Award for creating chair that restricts
how they sit now who the [ __ ] I mean
somebody gave her an award so what it is
is that the woman's chair forces the
woman to sit with their legs open and
the man's chair forces the man to sit
with his legs closed mm-hmm
so I don't really understand this
solving problem because they're just
they're passing the problem all over to
women yeah well who don't even have a
preference to sit with their legs open
and I know many times do I need to
explain this why don't why don't nobody
listen to me men have a dick and a balls
there's there's precious thing there's
all the sensitive tissues in between our
legs that restrict us from sitting do
you understand that women sit with their
legs closed because it's more
comfortable and Men sit with their legs
open because it's more comfortable you
have a vagina you idiot it nothing hangs
out it's easy it would be great if I
could sit with my legs closed but it's
not convenient especially a fat chubby I
got huge size there's no space for
anything down there do you understand
you know they won't know it so they
won't even acknowledge that though Gila
they never they won't even acknowledge
oh you want to know everything anything
I want you to open the article yes
because then they have pictures of
people sitting on the chairs and all
look so sad I want you to show it you're
on my side finally thank you scroll down
yeah there's a few I mean the woman
looks ridiculous yeah that's okay okay
this is how Minson how does it feel you
don't have a penis and this bro has been
cast
straighter if I see a guy like this he's
been castrated or is a micropenis I mean
you have to you have to consciously as a
man you have to consciously stomach the
discomfort to sit like that okay you
have to make a baby when your legs you
do howling you if I sit with my legs
apart it's very uncomfortable do you
want me to describe it to you nobody
makes these in these [ __ ] articles
and videos hello hello I don't
understand why no one acknowledged it
let me drive can we see that it I want
you to go down more Wow that okay hold
on okay yeah these are entertaining you
look sad
look at her legs widen open close your
legs you don't need that much know I
personally when I was pregnant I
couldn't sit with my legs crossed and I
didn't like it I prefer to Wow
so as I was saying you're more
comfortable with your legs closed yeah
let me get here tan from buzzfeed and
all the other feminists creating
mansplaining chairs man spreading chairs
my legs are closed right now this is how
you want me to sit for all of our
viewers thank you here you can see me in
the wide okay here's what's happening
tan and everybody listen to [ __ ] up cuz
I'm gonna get explain this once my balls
right now I can't hold this very long
are being smashed between my thighs okay
you're gonna take ties
yes it does not help you they're being
smashed there one my bright testicle is
being smashed in the middle of my thighs
it's hot and it's there's a lot of
pressure and yeah even even after this
amount of time I've been speaking it's
starting to hurt and I have to let up
the top testicle is being squished up
top yeah it's it's also very
uncomfortable the penis rests
comfortably at the top it's a it's a
testicle issue mm-hmm
use your imagination they hang down and
when it's hot as it is between the
thighs they hang even more do you know
why let me give you some male biological
lessons because apparently you don't
understand anything about being a man
the testicles are required to be held at
a certain temperature for the semen to
be viable ela hmm that's why they hang
what it's not for insert actor because
they need to be cool and when you forced
me to sit like that guess who's not
getting pregnant oh but maybe that's
what you wanted the whole time all men
to die and be castrated okay and so you
know all these fancy chairs and all
these BuzzFeed videos and all these TED
talks and all these sad pathetic little
men who were sitting I look how look at
look at this photograph like she's so
free sky and he's on a blue background
little [ __ ] boy so every other dive and
sit in that chair look at this look at
this guy how do you live with yourself
bro you betrayed your aunt your gender
you betrayed your gender look at this
Wow
oh so okay so here you've heard all the
arguments you've seen all they have to
say now allow me what is what you should
I read the bolt all I want to say is
that she have received a lot of explicit
messages from and who seemed to be under
the impression that she is trying to
castrate them and that she hates all men
don't which couldn't be further from the
truth
please don't see if you do that you are
even worse than she is if you go out of
your way okay now that I've gone extreme
one direction let me go the other way if
you go out of your way to target this
woman to find who she is and we don't do
that okay no if you are one of these
guys no thank ya that's what I'm trying
to say thank you so like it the goes and
finds her and sends her a mess yeah you
are you should be castrated do you
understand how pathetic and insane that
is bro I mean that's so insane so we can
make fun of her and goofing about it but
if you're gonna actually send her if it
if it upsets you
much dude you should be castrated I mean
that's so disturbing and weird bro
uh-uh you are way worse way worse than
her just making a stupid chair that we
can do here that is why I wanted to show
her side as well yeah it is important to
acknowledge it and she said I don't take
myself too seriously because for my work
I really wanted to be both important and
thought-provoking while also being
engaging and funny I think humor is
really interesting too in order to
tackle social issues good so then she's
really gonna appreciate my counterpoint
that's really actually I have a whole
topic I want to talk about these
pathetic guys I will do it on Friday
yeah I found this channel called um I
don't remember it's some insult I call
it the unbell manifesto you know it's
crazy like the the idea is held within
are so disturbing on and I watched one
video and YouTube was like recommending
me this release like if you're watching
this [ __ ] you've pretty much not only
hate women but I feel like you know 100%
hate women but it's like way beyond that
beyond that yeah but this but we'll talk
about make right now big towers I'm sure
like that or that's what they call
themselves it's men going their own way
oh thank you I was wondering what that
acronym you know I just found the video
in your dock that you're talking about
and you're right it's so crazy
oh my [ __ ] YouTube algorithm just I
just going to this I haven't even
watching it just clicking on it all of
the suggestions on the sidebar are like
more insel [ __ ] and this is like it
while we watched it together and I I
really couldn't believe it was real yeah
and it has a ton of you tons of positive
engagement so people are and I'm like I
was just listening and total shock and
disbelief because I mean I've only I've
been surrounded by reasonable dudes my
whole life and while we joke about
mansplaining this stuff apparently
there's a lot of guys out there that I
guess think that I'm speaking to them
and I am NOT
because this big house [ __ ] is I cannot
believe anyone actually believes this
stuff
it's cringy it's crazy scary yeah it's
scary and so so dude trust me it's not
like that you know yeah I can't believe
how far these guys take it but then yeah
it's like it's like YouTube algorithm
separate recommending alright [ __ ] I
mean there they are
whoa this McTell [ __ ] is [ __ ] meant
going their own way
I guess if that way is like what way is
that the wrong way I I don't even know
we'll talk about it
alright do like for people to understand
what we're talking about since we
haven't shown anything but it but anyway
i disavow that with with extreme
prejudice
so to counter her point I have only one
simple gift to show you okay little
clever engineer and all of your
co-conspirators out there who think that
manspreading is an issue I present you
with the one gift one short little video
clip to undo all all of your studies
people hate him for this one gift this
is a man on stage who sits down crosses
look man I've watched this so many times
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
shits up inside shock and pain he amazes
himself at how how much he could do you
see what I'm saying ladies okay okay
lady who mate just watch this look at
the sweet man
[Music]
I mean either tell me what's your
reaction to seeing this does it are you
gonna tell this poor man to stop
manspreading
[Laughter]
everytime it surprised me like everytime
it surprised me and you know the man
silently suffers nobody on his left or
right
nobody but this camera man knew what
happened this poor sweet old man trying
to mind his own business and minimize
the space he's occupying because there's
other dudes next to him they're
spreading their legs out too because
they also have not what is left has got
no problem well Tommy I think homies do
for some new pants think he passed on a
couple well I don't know what's going to
be free also he's older this does [ __ ]
droop slow man those the guy on the left
is like he's packed in but but the point
is is that I mean this could happen to
anyone any one of us I mean making that
face like somebody and this right
through his body
but I mean what really more do I need to
offer to you and rebuttal I feel like
you know at the national debate team she
comes with all this paperwork on all
these illegal documents and I say ladies
and gentlemen of the jury I present this
and I rest my case this guy is not a man
spreader he's just a dude with some well
troops well low troopers who [ __ ] sat
on his nuts wrong you know look how much
pain this poor [ __ ] in if you get you
telling me there's a chance that you're
gonna sit on the subway with your little
vagina and no issues no problem between
your legs you need empathy I mean women
have they complain and they complain
about men all the time and a lot of time
they're right but you want to talk about
empathy you will you have to acknowledge
we have testicles and they're delicate
that's the problem that they um they
make feel they make men feel like this
women really hate them and I think it's
a shame because there is a lot to
complain about with women men issues
right so I think it's a shame that they
make it so like they make it ridiculous
they make it even more dividing because
they go at man so strong that the only
reaction is to be like you know you're
you just hate you you can't have a
serious conversation about it when this
is the counter point but that's a really
good point you and that's why I love you
because you are smart and thoughtful and
reasonable and you you really are just
so fantastic and you have never once
given me any trouble about me
manspreading you I don't really have a
problem with what is your legitimate
problems you say that well what's one
off the top of your head if you cut an
issue that we should be discussing
between genders I think a real one that
goes a kind of less noticed is sometimes
it is harder for if you're like a woman
in a
and more men around you and everyone is
having conversation sometimes it kind of
really be harder to be heard yes that's
very true that's a real one that I'm
experienced I don't know if it's like
that for everyone I think that's a good
generalization and I found myself doing
that to you because you're well for
whatever reason I agree I have I I find
myself frequently doing that and then
having to consciously pull myself back
yeah but also you don't want to create
an environment where people are looking
I think what it is is just being
conscientious yeah you have to be you
being more thoughtful yeah be more
thoughtful of not just I think women but
people who are less I mean women tend to
be less assertive I think that's why and
I think that'll piss off some feminists
but I mean I'm sorry that's just I feel
like that's a bylaw just different women
can be assertive but Delta different way
so so like you said a lot of times
they'll get drowned out in a
conversation or I guess what people
would say maybe like Susan the CEO of
YouTube would say is that man she loved
my cutting her off a lot and sometimes
when we both handle stuff like
business-wise I feel like if something
came from you people will take us more
seriously versus if it came from me well
when it comes to negotiating but when it
comes to like dealing with manufacturers
abroad they even asked to talk to you
when they don't even know that I'm more
involved yeah we had partners in
Pakistan who wouldn't even talk to HeLa
yeah
so they both because they didn't take
her seriously they would when it when I
told my they would email me go around
ela and I'd be like talk to Ella yeah
I'd be like what the [ __ ] did yes but
yeah that's especially ironic just
knowing I mean ela is extremely business
savvy like it's written that's really
ridiculous that they will want to go
around her but I see what you mean and I
think that's more of an issue of of
Education I think growing up it helps to
teach young boys like that even more
than just literally sitting down and be
like son you have to remember right you
have to by example yeah by example but
yeah you have to sometimes listen more
and give other people an opportunity to
like myself I can be very especially in
a setting like this I don't know
assertive of my voice right so it's been
a learning process to learn to to allow
you to communicate yeah and parallel to
me but you do leave the show more so it
is sometimes it makes more sense for you
to anyway be about it yeah yeah or maybe
I think to talk about feminism and all
that I feel like it is totally just
leading by example right
I think action instead of just talking
like I think it's pretty cool that Teddy
fresh mm-hmm all 90% of our employees
are actually female and it's not we
didn't make it a conscious decision
that's just we just hired the best
people that we found we only have one
male employee yeah well she to wit men
alright Ben yeah but I think that you
know it's funny if we didn't we didn't
make the decision like I want female
know that in this room or you know well
also and maybe this breaks the
stereotype our lead designer is a male I
don't know you probably expect no
actually designers are is that a male or
into that's interesting but the thing it
you know we've also noticed I feel like
in the world of entertainment or at
least new media I feel like you in
particular are us are a perfect example
of a strong independent woman who has
her own achievements and her own
accomplishments under her belt and
whenever you see people getting
accolades and recognition for being like
a feminist or ever it's always these
typical people that have made a
super-loud and they try to make their
whole identity about that man is a man
power
women but what I don't know what they're
doing exactly other than talking about
it
so what I feel like yeah and and and
well and while you are actually living a
true the life of a true powerful
independent woman
you don't nobody's good even gonna
recognize you for doing that
because because I don't talk about
that's because you're doing what's
actually impactful which is living it
instead of just you know screaming about
how much of a feminist and tweeting
about all you know you know what I'm
saying no one will ever acknowledge a
true that crew hustle but I think you
you transcend even the the like you said
we're not we don't think about things
and that well the way that we and you
think about things is is really the way
that I think we all need to strive to is
that on my merits yeah
not not by not not based on what outcome
you want mm-hmm but based on the merits
itself but that's not progressive enough
apparently because you need to make
chairs that force people to sit like
this get a load of this guy
well I want to recognize you I I want to
recognize you you uh you are a strong
independent woman you're you're amazing
thank you that's what I always loved
about you from the beginning
independent super intelligent grounded I
don't feel super intelligent I know well
I mean who does really I mean who does
really people I mean look people always
have throughout my life said that I
they think I'm intelligent and I'm only
saying that as anecdotal I feel like a
[ __ ] idiot mm-hmm I swear to God I
don't feel intelligent okay I know that
if I think you're intelligent
I know if I took an IQ test I would
score very low hmm I feel like I'm sure
I would like barely get over a hundred
I'm not that smart I don't know why I
give off that impression I'm just not
that smart but anyway
Here I am making about me how dumb I am
but you are you're so capable and you're
so willing to go your own way and you're
so strong and you so you're not swayed
by it by by like perception and and and
cultural things you've always been very
much your own person and I just I you
know yeah I think you're sick all the
success you you have is all just from
your your strength and independence well
thank you and it's always been a
teamwork with us so you've always
enabled me to pursue all the stuff about
you no I'm saying I think what it is I
actually growing up I've always like
I've seen my mom work she was a
stay-at-home mom for a while but mostly
with my siblings not mood me and then
I've seen her always work and then when
I wanted something we were she would be
like okay this month I can buy you one
pair of jeans I always wanted like the
brands like I prefer to buy less but
spend more mm-hmm we don't really have a
lot of money so she would be like I'm
the 15 I get paid and this is how much I
can spend on you so 1 to 15 will go and
whatever you want but you get one thing
that's awesome
but I've always seen her work and the
what comes of it right and I've always
I've always had this thought like I'm
gonna be I'm gonna earn money for myself
so I can buy whatever I want I'm not
gonna have some guy you know giving me
money and me yeah cool living at his so
that hit that's always been in my mind
since being like a kid yeah because your
mom led by example mm-hmm your mom came
from a very traditional household and
she decided she was gonna enter the
workforce with very with no
qualifications yeah and just slow and
earn her own deep in a very conservative
household your dad probably didn't even
want her to work
I don't know yeah right your dad didn't
even want her to work and the funny
thing not coming funny but at at the end
towards like my dad's last year's she
was the only one actually working and
providing isn't that the best
it's like mother [ __ ] didn't even want
her working and here she is supporting
him but that's you know that's that's a
real strong woman
boo-yeah who breaks convention to do
what's best for her and she she led by
example and that's the best lesson you
can say words are what words are
seriously wind like you can have all the
wisdom and say all the right things but
it's it it's at it will go out one ear
and out the other it is weightless it
has nothing nothing in the face of
actually living an example I mean that's
what it's all about for kids I think I
always wanted a stronger my mom is
strong in some ways but she also went
out and made a good living and worked
and supported herself which was good
which was a really good example I think
yeah which is probably why I favored one
like that but moreover my dad was always
just such a dick to her all the time and
very demeaning to her of me growing up
like he like she doesn't know how to use
the remote so instead of just helping
her it turns into this whole thing about
like he's treating her like she's an
idiot
and it's like always that and that and
that and that and that and that and I
guess you can learn you know one of two
ways right and I never wanted to one of
the best things ever heard was the best
thing a man can do for his kids is to
respect their mother and I don't feel
like my dad ever really respected my mom
and I feel like it was it really was not
not healthy as a young man to to see
that somehow I came out of it with what
what I think is the right idea because
I've always been attracted to women that
I have a deep respect for
so I think I was looked actively looking
for a relationship
unlike theirs they're still together
happily married yeah they're not that
serious yeah there they are
they are like loving couple it's not
like they used to be worse but my butt
against suit they somehow my mom she's
crazy too you know like these people are
[ __ ] insane especially back in the
day like God but you really just words
are worthless man they so are worthless
you have to just you have to live it to
teach it mm-hmm and then you don't have
to speak a single word in short be good
to your mother be good to your mother in
short thank you to TMZ a lot of tangents
today is this real somebody told me I
saw this image of the air force train I
was going to ask you the same thing so
the air force is apparently training for
the area 51 invasion how do we find out
if this is real so here's a slide so one
of these guys in a military outfit is
giving a PowerPoint presentation to
other military personnel it says terms
to know Naruto running the act of
running like Japanese anime characters
Naruto Uzumaki leaving got the last name
which a person runs very fast with their
torso forward and arms back and the
instructor is demonstrating with his
arms back and its torso forward so you
know what I'm thinking about it again I
feel like there's no way this is real
well Dan do you have an answer though
wait yeah so I I did find an insight on
reddit of somebody you know it is reddit
so let's take it with a grain of salt
but somebody claiming to be in the
military and what they speculated it
probably was is I guess they do training
exercises about how to give a briefing
and take it seriously and they purposely
pick really absurd things so he gave as
an
Appl when he was in the middle Arian
they made them do a presentation about
like they're about to go to war with an
army of vegans mm-hmm and like they had
to like not laugh and like treat it as
if it were a real thing so he was
speculating that they're using this as
one of those examples but the
opportunity because I also saw in the
comments that this picture wasn't on the
internet previous to the area 51 page oh
well it could be Photoshop that's why
they would do it that's why they do one
thing right so that so it was a timely
presentation I mean I'm either way I
think it's real talking about the area
51 thing because I've seen reports that
the military you know they despite it
being a giant meme they have to take it
seriously because yeah at least 50
people are gonna die trying to get
exactly my brother will be there to
counter at all my brother should be a
good drone
oh god he'd get murdered no drones but
it but I think it is real one way or the
other I think the photo is real I think
the context okay yeah is potentially not
real yeah
but either way it's fantastic yeah and
it's somebody somehow like I wonder if
this is top-secret these photos is this
official top-secret business
I love how the guy in the bottom he's
like he's really oh my god
so there you have it the military is
preparing for the area 51 raid -
happening September 20th 3 a.m. to 6
a.m.
ending succinctly at 6 a.m. just in time
for some pancakes and eggs cats movie
trailer we always we have so much to
cover and there's too much to talk about
god yeah there's - I have too much here
it's already an hour and a half I have
too much to talk about
guys there's way too much to talk about
what have we talked about so far I need
a thumbnail do we have a something that
we can you know title and thumbnail if
we end it now it's been hour and a half
we've talked about TMZ we've talked
about Ethan Bradberry and we talked
about ant-man Spencer
pretty much it didn't lock the
background
Zack what am I gonna put Zacks dumb face
in the realtor wars I'll put a picture
of the two Realtors what can we do for a
thumbnail I mean that's demands plating
chairs pretty good that one is hard to
pin it down oh yeah well you'd have to
get a really good title like um women
proposes castrating man [ __ ] man there's
what would you title this episode right
now title like that we're gonna get in
the algorithm with those uh men going
their own way videos I'm saying if you
the titles that we castrating wouldn't
want to castrate men be good to your
mother that's right what if it's you
know people are gonna click wreath and
Bradbury I think it's got to be the man
spreading chairs mm-hmm yeah that's the
only topic with with teeth here and it's
a good one how about this Ethan destroys
the manspreading argument which is true
I think I do
but that's such a Ben Shapiro title
Ethan yeah well I mean but it's good
those videos have a lot of years at the
other hand you know can we can we all
agree that if we do it we're doing it
ironically
yeah always I say you can that's what
Hitler said about killing the Jews I
didn't manage that right that's a
license to murder you can do say
anything you want as long as it's ironic
Ethan and it Ethan ends the man
spreading epidemic okay once and for all
must watch I can go it ends I have a
problem with destroys Ethan annihilates
that's a long word now there is this
good content or what even a little peek
behind the scenes we can even highlight
this that's how many
you think of a thumbnail title that's
how matter we can get this is a banger
of a highlight now if we go with this
title what do you put in the tum no
because those chairs are not gonna know
you know the Naruto running in the
military would be funny I don't know hmm
but we talked about that for like two
minutes
yeah the chair we would have to get
creative cuz the chair you know we
should get just a random picture of men
spreading like a good one and and he's
on a noose hanging Ethan annihilates the
manspreading argument Ethan but maybe we
should be paired like a parody of entry
or Ethan destroys mansplaining argument
and the picture it's apparent okay yeah
of course we all agree no problem and
then I think she's pretty smart me so it
could be her with the woman's chair
men's chair if you blow that up you
could probably get a bitter pictures
because this one's real low-res like a
close-up and all maybe the people
sitting on those chairs oh that's pretty
depressing yeah I think we got something
there I mean the alternative that I
wanted to do for the title but we
haven't gotten time to get there is the
the ice cream looking challenge which i
think is good but we can talk about that
on friday we really got to move on
friday because we have so much to cover
dude i'm that's it okay on front we're
gonna have a long episode on Friday
because I gotta clear this list cuz we
have [ __ ] a lot dude including I've
got like the insult manifest so about
all these Instagram food one some things
here are starting to get old like the
face out of the whoopsie-daisy
yeah the face app there's so I'm okay
we're doing like five hours or a leak
which is gonna be like three hours on
Friday cuz we got a let's just I think
what we need to do is just move mm-hmm
just be like boom boom boom move baby
none of this tangent [ __ ] Oh women
empowerment
get real we're moving nice chat for
another day all right so we go right is
business
don't miss Friday's episode because we
mean business
don't ask me how we're doing no none of
this no no chitchat under this how's
your mother and trust me my mother been
great capiche haven't heard from my
mother haven't heard from your mother in
two months you've been good to your
mother he's almost too enthusiastic that
when he's like I've been great my mother
it's like whoa don't be so good to your
mother in weird you know I've been
watching Fear Factor a lot and there's
this one episode where the mom and the
son are like hugging and kissing all the
time I was like not that good
don't be everyone around them
acknowledge that they're being weird and
they're still being all touching nice so
weird there wasn't a second that they
weren't touching each other and like
whole episode the mom was she was yes
she must had him really young cuz she
looked she was attractive and she was
wearing very little and had big fake
titties kept showing her like yeah it's
very strange and he was probably like 18
and they were just embracing each other
like I feel like there's like a couple
there's almost no chance that they don't
they're not they had like the body
language that a couple would like
hugging and so if he was [ __ ] his mom
do you think the question is would they
be more just concealed with their
affection or would they not be able to
help it or would they think in their
minds that it was okay if they were
[ __ ] I feel like that is how they
would act because then you have to be so
twisted in your mind to do that mmm that
I feel like maybe for them that is toned
down usually it's just maybe I have no
idea you don't
towards the end if anyone's curious I
watched every single episode of fear
factor because with these like new no no
no no 160 episodes are like 157 episodes
they added to Hulu every single one and
because we're just I'm in front with
Theodore I have the most and the least
free time I've ever had in my life it's
very weird yeah so a lot we're just
feeding in and burping him and trying to
get him to go to sleep and we're just
sitting in front of the TV the whole day
until watch 157 episodes of Fear Factor
since he's been born because you can't
really watch good content because then
you're not paying attention enough so
you're wasting it so and you got to
watch something that you can just kind
of like look away and then look back and
you're still not missing anything right
so Fear Factor is perfect
I mean I loved it it was really
interesting though because so the show
was cancelled ultimately because the the
first couple seasons were like huge
success
crazy ratings world phenomenon yeah and
the ratings were falling off every
season falling off falling off and I
when I first started I was like how's
that possible the first episode is so
shocking I could not believe what I was
seeing the very first challenge in that
first episode they tie the contestants
to the back of a [ __ ] horse and drag
their ass at full speed on the ground on
like a dirt like rocky and they had they
had to hold on to a rope for as long as
I could and they were getting [ __ ] up
they were getting like their shirt
Wonder's shirt was torn completely off
they were all bloody and cut up and it
was like everyone was like terrified it
was shocking and I think I don't know
for what reason if it was legal or what
but like as the show went on I feel like
less actually dangerous things happen or
they were like and that that's what was
so great about that especially first and
second episode is that
like every episode was just shocking
human first second seasons yes sir
like as a how the [ __ ] they get away
with that
it's literally like they used to execute
people that way where they drag them at
the back of a horse
yeah it's literally the dudes shirt was
shredded off his body and then the other
side of it is the animal torture oh my
god it's so so you would never be able
to do it today
dude it's it's it's hard to watch the
worst thing I saw so a lot of times
they're blending up insects live insects
like worms and cockroaches and beetles
and the ship they always turn them into
smoothies so they blend him alive but
the craziest one was they had a huge
bullfrog like this big that they blended
alive and showed what the [ __ ] yeah I
haven't I still haven't seen that part
cuz I was looking away with Tia door
mm-hmm I gotta go back and a [ __ ]
they I mean it there was other I mean I
even the insects is hard to watch me
it's not like there there's like huge
beetles and cockroaches and worms and
they're just they're alive and they're
just blending them alive and showing it
on camera and then the person just
straight chugs it it's like the most
disgusting one that I've seen was there
and dead rat that they all blinded and
so good and then they have to drink it
set it up yeah you set it up they go out
to this if you've been in New York City
you know there's there's all these
hotdog stands where they saw a hotdog
for like a dollar and they take it out
of this old water with tongs so they're
on the streets of New York City what
does he take out not a hotdog a dead rat
a whole dead rat puts it in a blender
with a little sewage water and [ __ ]
blends it right there entire dead rat
hair skeleton tail I mean everything
it's a whole rat a lot of hair
really close and then he puts it in a
bowl and gives him a spoon and they have
to I was actually shocked because they
ate it all like that there was two guys
I had a challenge and they both didn't
have any trouble eating that dead wrap
which shocked the hell out of me they
were talking about they had to like hair
stuck in the teeth fear factors a crazy
show man I watched every [ __ ] episode
but I have to admit it got really boring
towards the end and watching Joe Rogan's
uh transformation is funny too like you
can tell his testosterone levels are
going through the roof towards the end
like they came back for the last season
they were they came back for like a
little special and he comes back and
he's all tatted up both of his arms and
full tats he's he's like more yakked
than ever you can tell he's been
shooting testosterone into his testicles
and uh and taking alpha brain and [ __ ]
like apparently some guys sued them for
that rat episode oh really
because I struggled at Friendly's it
couldn't stomach what he watched well
I'm not surprised wait it was just a
viewer just a viewer yeah
well so I think the most obscene stuff
I've seen and I'm like an expert because
I I walk I don't think anyone's watched
as much for your factor as I did in that
time I would just watch it every day all
day did you know that they just recently
revived it no they didn't well I did
apparently it's on MTV and the host is
Ludacris now know why are you kidding
wait how long have I been on since
twenty seventeen recently yeah there
that's gotta be so tame we're gonna have
to wait out Ludacris I saw in my opinion
Joe Rogan made that show that show would
have been nothing and I'll tell you why
because Joe Rogan is such like an alpha
male character and he peer pressure's
people he shames people human humiliates
people and he really amps up the
environment and he actually is really
good encouraging people through the
challenges who wouldn't otherwise do it
and he's so
he's so perfect for that show he made
that show Ludacris give me a [ __ ]
break
yeah that's kind of hard to picture but
yeah apparently it's a thing two seasons
not like there was one scene let me tell
you about how Joe Rogan is good for the
show I'm telling you I'm an expert at
Fear Factor he goes there's one
challenge where they have to eat a giant
Madagascar hissing cockroach they're
huge living cockroaches
oh that's nothing on that show and so
one of the girls I think it was a
celebrity it was a celebrity edition and
one of them failed the competition so
they're like okay I'll tell you what if
you eat this hissing Madagascar and
cockroach hole you can come to the
finals and she's like no [ __ ] way no
[ __ ] way and Joe Rogan's like I'll eat
one and he takes an entire mmm
hissing cockroach I mean they're huge
man I'm talking like both of your thumbs
together just dropped you a link with
pictures of him yeah they're [ __ ] it
you have a picture Kyle it's not oh you
don't want to see a picture you see how
big their I mean it this guy's this it's
it's dare Norma's and so he puts the
whole [ __ ] thing in his mouth and he
eats it he's trying to be a badass he
was really badass but he started gagging
but but it he was gagging and I think
laughing because he's shocked by how
disgusting was it alive yeah yeah yeah
they like live scorpions a tarantula
leeches yeah I can't hang with that [ __ ]
man no watch that show and so he goes he
gets it down he goes that's why I'm the
because he had he can
he had times almost yaks he at times but
he always holds it together but the
workers are the worst thing I ever saw
on that show was they put the
contestants again always the worst ones
they somehow get through but they put
the contestants in a tank full of cow
intestines and what they had to do was
bite into the intestines and
out the [ __ ] spit into a cup and then
drink it so they had these huge long
intestines and they would bite into it
and would be squirting everywhere and
they would suck it up or they would like
sponge it out like that and they would
spit it into a cup and would they bite
in it was really juicy at what squirt
everywhere it's full of [ __ ] and then
they had to drink it I'm like how the
[ __ ] even how was that and people always
do how do you survive that thing yes how
would they do it
well that one actually nobody had any
problem with and their rat and they
wanted to discuss them in the move those
those those Jews ate it like chocolate
ice cream
yeah they did so about that one the guy
sued them for two and a half million
dollars to just lay me he felt so
disgusted for watching the stunt and he
felt dizzy and lightheaded and vomited
and he claimed that his disorientation
was so severe that he ran into a doorway
and seriously injured himself for that
as a [ __ ] and then the judge throw it
out thanks obviously damn that that was
during the era where everyone was just
suing for any yeah and also so you told
me that they had an episode of when the
contestant had to drink donkey semen
yeah didn't air oh yeah because it was
the only episode that NBC ever rejected
whether it was a twins episode you can
find it online but they cut it and
actually it wasn't on who I wasn't sure
because they rereleased it but it's a
twins episode and there's these really I
frezzer I remember cute like petite
blonde twins and he goes well you'll
have to do he brings out a huge picture
of donkey semen and they have to chug it
boat so one of them is donkey urine and
one of them is monkey semen and they
both and one has to choose which one and
they and I'm thinking like how is this
part and they do it they do it they do
it and then there's a guy couple that
does it - chugging an entire picture of
semen yeah
crazy right
then there's another one so that was the
only episode that was cut but they used
to do like the stunts they would do in
the beginning were so insane like mm-hmm
they would shut down like huge parts of
Los Angeles and city work and get like
access crazy to like huge skyscrapers in
LA and they're crawling out and it was
really amazing and then towards the end
I think they just got lazy or lower
budget because they were just in the
desert on the crane pretty much but in
the way they had bigger budget because
they started doing all these crazy
explosions and like annoying ours every
time the producers didn't understand no
it's like more money it's the YouTube
bread syndrome yeah they are us and all
of our creator fans that we know
whenever they pitched the YouTube bread
they're like okay but we need to justify
that for charging people I guess it's
YouTube premium now yeah and boat so we
need to spend more money I'm like well
[ __ ] shut up like I pitched to them I
pitched them a really good concept I
wanted to make this character the
vapenation guy except I go to different
subcultures and study the soap culture
and assimilate mm-hmm so every episode I
become a different guy not so like one
episode I'd be like become a skater and
they said that it was too low-budget
something that I can make that would
exist in front of a paywall
I'm like are you [ __ ] stupid here I
need good people that's what I'm paying
for
not explosions I think for good people
they don't get it these people don't
understand what makes a good show they
don't understand it and they work in the
industry the other one that was super
obscene was like they have cow blood
like a swimming pool of just cow blood
done done a couple of times and to see
someone covered in blood like they were
bobbing for cow hearts or something and
they come up and their head is just
covered in blood and it's just so it's
so sick it really is just so sad and the
other thing about this show is that it's
such a timepiece it's
finding a Worcester tips puka-shell
necklace it's all the girls are like
models fake tits though yeah I was so
long ten and they're always wearing a
bikini yeah always
and then they always make sure to have a
water challenge and then they do like a
slope an up the body oh yeah they when
they take off their clothes they always
do like know everything to try to
pretend like that's not what they're
doing they try to be cool about it but
it's so obvious and all the guys look
like before four it's great i I
seriously loved every almost every
episode yeah it's on Hulu every episode
I highly recommend it but a parent so
apparently the show obviously was so
popular at first and then tapered off
but in syndication it's like huge it's
like a huge huge show like 700 million
bucks
I wonder if Joe has a back end on that
must right cuz I know it's not for sure
he wasn't that famous when he started
doing it huh but he did he did every
single episode so I'm pretty sure that
he got some good conditions and he was
he wasn't super famous but he was on
Newsradio by that time well i like he
was like a known actor and yeah but no
he was an unknown but this show made him
famous in the beginning but i think they
kept doing more seasons there must have
been a renegotiate yeah yeah yeah yeah
because he really makes the show but
they could have just give him a really
nice per episode fee not knowing that it
would be like so syndicated yeah because
I mean I'm sure Joe I'm sure Joe's
really well off but I don't know because
that's like if he had back in on fear
factor that's like 100 million like
crazy numbers maybe not what do I know
what the [ __ ] do I know
I don't know it work is if if the show
made seven hundred million dollars in
syndication I don't know what the normal
back-end let's say one and a half
percent because he's just a guy maybe
it's five percent residual well like I'm
not completely sure either
but it seems like a lot to get a whole
black 5% it's usually per airing more so
then just like a flat fee when they said
no to syndication okay well every time
it airs he gets a little bit of money
assuming he he does have residuals on it
well if he got 5% which seems high to me
I don't know but that'd be thirty five
million dollars it's a lot of dope yeah
it's a lot of dough a lot of donkey
semen you can buy with that but I'm sure
he I'm sure he makes that about every
episode of the podcast he's all good but
it's all on Hulu dude
I would totally check that out if you're
just chilling and once I mean especially
the first season I think he'll be hooked
but the first season just shock the
[ __ ] hell out of me the only
challenges i always hated was a woman
thugs
so boring dumb oh yeah they have it's
just ridiculous some of the times it's
just so unfair like you pit a 90-pound
girl I guess a 200-pound guy and then
they have a dog come attack them they're
in like a dog attack suit and the dog
weighs 90 pounds so of course the dog is
going to tackle the girl of the ground
and the guys clear with like absolutely
no challenge at all the best ones are
when it's like a mix a perfect mix where
the women aren't evil even playing field
with the men sometimes they really
surprise you you would think like
there's no way a guy wouldn't win it and
yeah woman dies when the woman yeah the
women are fierce competitors on that
show pretty funny
definitely like remember the last
challenge of the first episode again
blew my mind
they had a taxi hanging from a crane at
this absurd angle just insane angle near
the climate of the back and get a flag
and they made it rain and they made it
rain so I was like how the [ __ ] can
anyone do this and of course no I don't
well I think one day I could complete it
but the first guy slipped off and like
almost broke his arm you trying to catch
on and grab himself and he [ __ ]
destroyed his arm so the first episode
was amazing like people were almost
dying there being so I was just it was
amazing right yeah and it just I don't
know if either it wore off the shock or
got more conservative and think about it
but dude I don't know that first season
was just [ __ ] like boom-boom-boom and
ever every episode is a banger you know
and then there's really fun once listen
to me going on about Fear Factor there's
really funny ones where the contestants
suck and they just won't do anything and
Gio just burr rates that hell out of
them those are really fun to watch and
there's even episode where Joe gets in a
fight with a dude it puts him in a
headlock that's pretty big yeah it's
great so yeah that's it there and there
you go I'm complaining here I just want
another extra half an hour when I could
have covered all these topics but I had
to [ __ ] how the way we like to thank
Hulu for sponsoring this episode that
way
I do like Hulu though I like it anything
about the cable i watch you a little
more than netflix at this point oh I
know why is because they have all the
reality shows and they have all the new
[ __ ] like you almost don't even need
cable through it because they have
ongoing shows like bachelor nation what
up they put the new bachelor and you
just have to wait an extra day but I'm
paying $150 for dish and they [ __ ]
suck [ __ ] I can't wait to cancel it
I'd rather suck the [ __ ] out of a cow
intestine can pay them another 150 bucks
that's not true oh yeah and the best
part of Fear Factor it's only fifty
thousand dollar prize the [ __ ] that
these people go through no no it's not
it's not good enough it's really not
like maybe in the first season in like
the early 2000s I mean I don't know
where inflation was at but 10 episode
ten seasons later it's still 50,000 and
the [ __ ] that they go through sometimes
they go out their head yeah they do have
special hundred thousand and the
millions I gave you guys are gonna love
this
they do some they did like a couple of
times a million dollar special where
it's like seven seven episodes long and
in the fine print they say the million
dollars is paid to the winner over 40
years
so they're still being paid off now the
winners of that [ __ ] I was like twenty
five thousand dollars a year which I
mean is nice but like you're not a
millionaire and then I'm imagine you had
a really good point of yeah I'm just
imagining these people like they're kind
of low life like just like imagine a
dude who won fear factor twenty years
ago and he doesn't work he just collects
his $25,000 fear factor pension so
anyway it's it was like bad for them
because it put them in this middle
position of like I don't need to work
right but then you're getting a little
point about and then as the years go on
inflation hits you by the time they pay
your ass back over forty years that
money's gonna be worth like so much less
right yeah cuz in 40 years yeah probably
like half of what it was 40 years even
knows of the government hasn't resolved
it but I just love them the image of one
of these guys like yeah one fear factor
I want fear factor 30 years ago I've got
another 10 years left on my pension 25
thousand a year is so funny and the fine
print 40 years and then that person ends
up with no education no career oh it's
[ __ ] cursed their whole life winning
the show was the worst thing that ever
happened to them you know because they
you think you're a millionaire but
you're so far from a millionaire you're
so far from a millionaire mm-hmm you're
basically making the salary of a
full-time McDonald's employee not to
poopoo their service I mean god bless
for that ain't a millionaire like what
are the chances they went out and got
gainfully employed and was just like I'm
gonna make an extra twenty five thousand
on top of this someone who appeared on
fear factor hell no they're celebrating
and then that's basically what the Big
Lebowski is about she was a winner on
fear factor like 35 years prior and he's
about to run out of money
god bless love the fear factor
all right we're gonna have to try to
make this thumbnail work mm-hmm [ __ ]
man spreading we're going to go crazy on
this one
Ethan destroys feminist ideology in one
fell swoop mag domination make doubt
Ethan goes mgtow can you make a dumber
sounding name MIG though like dude if
you're gonna try to be badass make it ow
sounds like sounds like what Steven
Seagal does you know what Steven Seagal
looks like he's off yeah it's like a
really shitty martial arts for fat old
dudes McDow alright let's wrap this up
alright Friday is gonna be max impact so
y'all don't go and miss that right ela
it's business guys this has been your
parents Ethan and yo decline the only
people that truly care about you in this
world your best friends your only
companions I mean this is everything hey
tree podcast is everything cuz without
us who's gonna tell you what's going on
in the world who's gonna tell you what
to think and who's gonna listen your
problems people around you are just
trying to control you the people are
around you're rolling hills here's our
address you can send us your 10% of your
income a tip if you were a I say that
right tip tight hey dat site but if what
the church get 10% and I don't how I do
way more for you guys in the church what
does the church do for you you know what
I mean like seriously think about it oh
I'm a pastor I'm not talking about the
same dumb [ __ ] I did last week I change
it up at least and you can watch at home
way more comfortable so they are my
dress will be in the description you
could save me 10% the h-street
type TIFF right then die yes yes you can
send us your money thank you thank you
we will see on Friday we love y'all we
appreciate you this has been a while off
the rails experience this episode was
off the rails song is nearing the end
and said alright so guys we'll see on
Friday where we're gonna be on the rails
bye bye bye
[Music]
[Music]